hey everybody we are live I was not
planning on being live today did a live
stream on Monday night with the Bernie
Sanders Fox News Town Hall did a live
stream last night long live stream with
the results from the sort of Super
Tuesday - primaries the second Super
Tuesday as as it was but I just found
out a couple of hours ago that Donald
Trump will be doing a major address
tonight from the Oval Office on
coronavirus and despite the fact that
everything coronavirus is demonetised on
youtube for now although that may be
changing this is important stuff and so
we are going to be live scheduled for at
the top of the hour we're about 16
minutes away so I'm gonna go through
some of the latest data math and data on
coronavirus and then we will have the
address at the top of the hour and then
we will discuss it this could be five
minutes
at the top of the hour it could be a
half hour if I had to say I think it'd
be closer to five minutes than thirty
maybe something like 10 12 14 minutes
questions about what resources are going
to be deployed by the government Donald
Trump remember just I mean hours ago
talking about this will go away on its
own this is no big deal
everything's fine - at this point
clearly believes that it is serious and
my Trump has no idea what's going on so
my best hope is that he is simply going
to put in place people who will be
empowered to do things that's the best
hope because he doesn't know what's
going on he can't be counted on he also
thinks he knows more than everybody else
so the idea is hopefully someone has
gotten his ear and says hey put me in
charge of this not pense someone who is
serious and that's sort of sort of what
we can hope for so if you have questions
comments or anything else now as we wait
for this to start you're on youtube send
them in via super chat they'll show up
in the bottom right if you have anything
and you're watching on Twitch include
your question or comment with your
twitch subscription message and it'll
show up up there toady capote just
signed up with twitch prime and I very
much appreciate that we also have a very
modest membership goal today 25 members
nothing crazy like the eighty nine or
hundred that we've done in the past we
do have a coupon code
always appreciate people who support the
streams particularly when they are
coronavirus related which is flatly
demonetised by YouTube I won't go into
the details of exactly what's going on
with that I have a couple of segments on
that already I want to look at some of
the numbers so listen it's like there's
a lot I'll turn the volume up on this
just so we hear it when it starts I want
to look at some of the data let me
refresh this so we have like a hundred
more cases than when I looked so let
there it's a lot of bad information and
there's some things that could be signs
that things are starting to turn around
of course coronavirus cases is the total
cumulative number this includes people
who are no longer sick that's important
to keep in mind 4,600 deaths
68,000 recovered one of the things
that's important to look at is active
cases and how serious those cases are
let's look first at active cases the
cumulative number will go up forever
because even if you know you can have a
hundred cases of something everybody
recovers the next person that gets sick
that's number 100,000 and one active
cases in ver is very important because
active cases tells us how many people
currently are infected who could pass
the infection to someone else now of
course this all assumes we know the
numbers of cases and we don't but to the
extent that that we know of active cases
we don't know obviously people who
haven't been tested it started declining
for a while and then right at the
beginning of the month it started going
back up and active cases is increasing
the other thing that's important is mild
vs. serial a serious of the known cases
we used to have about eighteen nineteen
twenty percent that we're considered
serious or critical that's gone down to
11 percent doesn't mean there's actually
fewer serious or critical cases what it
means is we're finding out that a lot of
people with very mild symptoms actually
have it that's good only in the sense
that if 20 people really were going to
be serious or 20% we're really going to
be serious or critical that is a much
more serious thing than if it's 11%
still bad no question about it okay
deaths and cases of course both
increasing
very very dramatically this table here
and let's see if I can get us a better
view of the table there we go
and we are standing by for Trump's
livestream I see the super chats I see
everything and I'm going to get to them
a couple of things to look at and I
think I probably will want my calculator
for some of this stuff because of you
know math and data a couple of the
things to look at one bit of very good
let's focus on what's good because
there's a lot of really really bad here
one thing that's good is when you look
at the China numbers this is now a
common day for China eighteen new cases
and often a thousand to fifteen hundred
people who have been cured who have
recovered so to speak and what you are
seeing here is that even though China
has had by far the largest number of
cases the number of active cases in
China is about to fall below the number
of active cases in Italy that Italy's
having a major problem but also very
interestingly if you look at cases per
population China was at the top
China is all the way down here now
because of China's large population
China does seem to have this under
control if other countries don't get it
under control that's not it's not going
to be a very good thing the other thing
that I want to look at is in terms of
total cases you see South Korea here
this is a very good sign there have been
60 deaths in South Korea with 77 55
cases that's a death rate of only 0.77
why do we care about that the reason we
care about that is when we heard about a
death rate of three point four which
would be roughly thirty four times the
death rate of the flu it sounds
absolutely and completely dystopian not
that a point the flu is about point
fifteen is the death rate what we have
been finding out is that that early
death rate was very skewed towards the
people diagnosed in wuhan early on that
was an older population on average and
in I've just been reading about this
apparently you might have seen that
early on there was a big there were many
more men who had died than women we
didn't know why that was it is surmised
that because of cultural reasons in
China men are far more likely
to smoke than women any underlying
disease and of course smoking is
terrible for the respiratory system this
is a respiratory illness that may
explain why the death rate was so skewed
towards men early on and in general it
may explain why the death rate was so
high early on the fact that South
Korea's death rate is only 0.77 and of
course a lot of that is the fact that
they've been testing large groups of
people that is reassuring still 0.77
compared to 0.15 for the flu it's still
about six times higher but it is not 34
times higher that's like a you know tiny
tiny bit of good news um one other thing
that I wanted to point out that is
potentially okay news Italy's having a
major problem when you look at you know
eight twenty seven deaths over 12 for 62
that's a six point six percent death
rate that's terrible we don't know if
part of it is the systems are too
overwhelmed to provide care to everyone
we don't know if the systems are
inferior in some way we don't know if
it's an older sicker population is
smoking a factor we don't know there is
one just the tiniest tiniest bit of okay
news out of Italy and it's this right
here which is that from March 9th to
March 10th meaning from from the day
before yesterday - yesterday see how the
rate of increase slowed down that could
be an inflection point in an ideal world
the controls that Italy put in place
about 10 days ago hopefully this is the
hope okay the hope is you see this big
very steady larger and larger increase
but then yesterday it slowed down a tiny
bit you can see here this was about 1800
new cases in a day this was about 1500
new cases in a day this was about 1200
from March 9th to March 10th there were
under a thousand new cases that's the
smallest number of new cases in Italy
now going back for a while my hope is
and this is not political for me this is
I have a friend in Italy who's home with
a fever right now and may or may not
have this we just don't know the hope is
that that's an inflection point and if
you know if Italy if we find out at the
update that they had only 900 new cases
on March 11th it's a decrease in the
rate of new cases that would be a good
thing and as you can see here eight my
numbers weren't too far off 1800 only
977 yesterday we are waiting right now
for the update for for March 11th and we
will see that so those are just a few
thoughts let me see if I had anything
else let me let's stay on here I'll
address super chats and everything else
that's going on and then I'll go back to
some of some of the other data and the
math but I'm doing my best to keep
everybody apprised apprised of what's
going on here
if you are just joining please like and
subscribe on YouTube I really do
appreciate we want as many people as
possible to see the streams with our
commentary and it costs you nothing
that's just a small favor that I ask of
you and very much appreciate that okay
super chats that are coming in you won't
be able to see the first few because
they're kind of above where where you
can see on the screen
Jason Aldrich says new single dads
suburbanite what should I do with food
scraps trash pickup is not until
Saturday thanks have no idea Jason
that's gonna be something you you may
want to google name withheld says the
gist of this message will be everyone
stay calm me and Elon Musk will be on
Mars we I don't know what to expect from
Trump here Marcus Robert Johnson says
can any doctor or judicial power
override Trump's decisions with a
possible epidemic like this there are
things Trump's just not involved in and
those are the ones we have to hope are
being handled by professionals clever to
swear says could this corona virus
potentially affect tens of millions of
people like the swine flu it could and
it's all about the trajectory of those
new cases Jeff the god of biscuits has
grabbed a youtube subscription thank you
Matt Chavez says my work sent everyone
to work from home today
understandable Michaels way Goff says I
am NOT an epidemiologist but I heard
Italy's death threat could be due to a
different more lethal strain of the
virus yes so in the same way that that
is something that is being hypothesized
about that this huge Italy death rate
could be because of a more serious
strain
there's also the hope I call it a hope
that a less serious strain may be in the
US and in some other places and
hopefully it would lead to a lower death
rate once the full scope of the of the
cases is known important so let's talk
about the US by the way officially right
now the death rate is 38 over 1305
that's a two point nine percent death
rate sorry about that two point nine
percent there are estimates that there
are anywhere from three to seven
thousand active cases in the United
States we've not been testing if there
are three thousand active cases in the
US that's a one point two percent death
rate if there are six thousand active
cases in the US that's only a 0.6
percent death rate I actually hope that
there are way more cases that we find in
the sense that it would suggest both
that this is far less lethal that we are
hopefully relatively well equipped to
deal with the cases on an individual
medical basis Trump of course wants to
keep the case number low I actually
would be reassured if the case number is
high because nobody believes this number
this number is completely unbelievable
1300 cases if we found out there have
actually been six thousand it tells us
that the the rate is kept quite low you
know it's it's six of one half a dozen
or the other there's a lot of
considerations here I don't want to make
light of any particular particular
statistic in any way let me say a few
thank-yous over on Twitch
Fuli has grabbed a twitch subscription
Aspire 55 slice FN has subscribed liquid
ice says University of Wisconsin System
is suspending in-person meetings for
classes local government planning for
remote work love the show David sounds
like you're coming to me from inside a
helium balloon I will have to let you go
apologies yes please don't please don't
hang up on me we're just about four
minutes from the start of donald trump
speech if you're joining us please
consider supporting the stream by
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
if you're new to what we're doing here
welcome this is the david pakman show
channel we are primarily supported
surely on anything coronavirus which is
completely demonetized by YouTube as a
sensitive event consider grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com no one has
signed up tonight we have a very modest
goal of 25 and you can get a great
discount with the code 2020 now it takes
merely a second let me make sure that
the website is not down because
sometimes there is a lot of demand when
I mention that and the website can go
down and that it's embarrassing when
that happens quite frankly when the
website goes down it's not good for
anybody no it's not the website is up
consider grabbing a subscription there
but certainly make sure to LIKE and
subscribe if you are watching on youtube
ok other super chats coming in let's see
here Jayden Trent has signed up parents
here and comes in with a thousand
Swedish kronor super chat Wow I don't
know how much that is but it sounds like
it's a lot right is that uh how much is
five a thousand Swedish kronor
I'll check an English doctor who have a
very sober channel with connection all
over the world
I have seen that doctors channel the
British doctor who's doing daily updates
and I think it's very very good ok a
thousand Swedish kronor is a hundred and
five dollars Thank You Pere I really
appreciate that
Rasmus haymaker says is Mads Bach to
blame for his Bernie ignorance [ __ ] I
have no idea what that means
awesome gaming says the United States
number are undone because there are no
tests that's right farmer Kip says my
rook on a four is tied to a pond it's a
bad rook and could be a problem later
what should I do
no idea I'd have to see the full the
full game and I'm only rated 1300 so you
probably want to ask somebody else let's
see here kwik-e-mart has grabbed a
youtube subscription mike says how much
of the stock market reaction to the
virus is pure fear how much is due to
rodney and his tiny big little legs
there there's a lot of what's going on
with the market is of course fear but we
only know that in retrospect that's the
crazy thing only later will we find that
out let me say thank you and welcome to
I hope I say this
correctly liesl Leuthold
lia zulu theld is new member number one
tonight at join pakman.com thanks so
much Lee as well I really do appreciate
your support we are standing by for
Donald Trump in just about a minute at
this point in time if you're just
joining me on twitch Facebook or YouTube
welcome make sure on twitch to hit that
follow button maybe grab a twitch
subscription if it's uh if it's up your
alley
if you're joining us over on YouTube
please do hit the like button there's 50
100 people watching and only 700 likes
we're not really this this horrible at
liking the stream is my prediction I
think we could do much better than that
and certainly make sure that you hit
that subscribe button as well if you're
watching on YouTube clever to swear says
keep Biden in Sanders quarantined
otherwise Tulsi has a chance of winning
of the primaries I was thinking the same
thing
Hideyoshi Lacan says if the world ends
I'll go out watching David Pakman if the
world ends I may go out streaming we may
we may all go out at the same time Marlo
Stanfield says Fox News said the
president is likely to push the deadline
of taxes back I just filed mine
yesterday I should have taken advantage
no I I'm getting a refund so I actually
am glad I got it done clever to swear
says what's your favorite pandemic movie
I've not really seen many I have I have
to tell you Ross Park says hey David I'm
a right-leaning libertarian but I listen
to you to keep a balanced perspective
and I think you're doing great work
thank you and keep it up Thank You Ross
I appreciate that
azeema Abu Khalil David to what degree
do you think the Bernie or bust movement
will be an impediment to Biden's chances
at winning the presidential election I
think it will be about a 10 to 15
percent impediment if I had to say wow I
mentioned liking the stream and 800 more
people liked it and we're at 1,500 likes
already that's crazy
we are actually potentially based on the
the way that the stream is going we may
set a live concurrent viewer record here
if people keep liking and subscribing I
was just on the phone with my youtube
rep today
and he confirmed to me yes when people
enter your stream and very quickly like
and subscribe that tells YouTube the
content is so freakin compelling that
YouTube must tell other viewers that
they should also check out that stream
that these were not exactly his words
but it's close enough right let me say
welcome to Patrick's Kelly
Patrick's Kelly is new member number two
tonight at join pakman.com our target is
25 and we are at - ok I mean you know
it's ten percent you can sign up at join
pakman.com I also want to thank over on
Twitch a grow light a grow light has
subscribed with twitch prime squarely
says you are amazingly good pack keep it
up
sway bros ok here is Donald Trump let's
see
my fellow Americans tonight I want to
speak with you about our nation's
unprecedented response to the corona
virus outbreak so he's already brackets
started in China and is now spreading
throughout the world I'm taking notes
today the World Health Organization
officially announced that this is a
global pandemic we have been in frequent
contact with our allies and we are
marshalling the full power of the
federal government and the private
sector to protect the American people
this is the most aggressive and
comprehensive effort to confront a
foreign virus in modern history I am
confident that by Counting and
continuing to take these tough measures
we will significantly reduce the threat
to our citizens and we will ultimately
and expeditiously defeat this virus from
the beginning of time nations and people
have faced unforeseen challenges
including a large-scale and very
dangerous health threats this is the way
it always was and always will be it only
matters how you respond and we are
responding with great speed and
professionalism bragging our team is the
best anywhere in the world at the very
start of the outbreak we instituted
sweeping travel restrictions on Chow my
god it's all bracket in place the first
federally mandated quarantine in over 50
years we declared a public health
emergency and issued the highest level
of travel warning on other countries as
the virus spread it's horrible infection
and taking early intense action we have
seen dramatically fewer cases of the
virus in the United States that are now
present in Europe you're not testing the
European Union failed to take the same
precautions attack history of travel
from China and other hotspots as a
result a large number of new clusters in
the United States were seeded by
travelers from Europe
everything here someone else helping
with our top government health
professionals I have decided to take
several strong but necessary actions to
protect the
health and well-being of all America ok
let's say to keep new cases from
entering our shores we will be
suspending all travel from Europe to the
United States Wow 30 days the new rules
will go into effect Friday at midnight
Wow these restrictions will be adjusted
subject to conditions on the ground
unbelievable B exemptions for Americans
who have undergone appropriate
screenings and these prohibitions will
not only apply to the tremendous amount
of Trade and cargo Trump's rise various
other things as we get approval anything
coming from Europe to the United States
is what we are discussing these
restrictions will also not apply to the
United Kingdom at the same time we are
monitoring the situation in China and
the South Korea the South as their
situation improves we will re-evaluate
the restrictions and warnings I can't
ignore the earth noise for a possible
early opening earlier this week I met
with the leaders of health insurance
industry of course who have agreed to
waive all co-payments for coronavirus
treatments extended surance coverage to
these treatments and to prevent surprise
medical billing we are cutting massive
amounts of red tape to make antiviral
therapies available in record time these
treatments will significantly reduce the
impact and reach of the virus
additionally last week I signed into law
an eight point three billion dollar
funding bill to help CDC and other
government agencies fight the virus and
support vaccines treatments and
distribution of medical supplies testing
and testing capabilities are expanding
rapidly day-by-day we are moving very
quickly the vast majority of Americans
the risk is very very low young and
healthy people can expect to recover
fully and quickly if they should get the
virus the highest risk is for elderly
population with underlying health
conditions
the elderly population must be very very
careful in particular we are strongly
advising that nursing homes for the
elderly suspend or medically unnecessary
visits in general older Americans should
also avoid non-essential travel in
crowded areas my administration is
coordinating directly with communities
with largest outbreaks and we have
issued guidance on school closures
social distancing and reducing large
gatherings smart action today will
prevent the spread of the virus tomorrow
every community faces different risks
and it is critical for you to follow the
guidelines of your local officials who
are working closely with our federal
health experts and they are the best for
all Americans it is essential that
everyone take extra precautions and
practice good hygiene each of us has a
role to play in defeating this virus
wash your hands clean often use surfaces
cover your face and mouth if you sneeze
or cough Trump looks ill and most of all
if you are sick or not feeling well stay
home to ensure that working Americans
impacted by the virus can stay home
without fear of financial hardship oh I
will soon be taking emergency action
which is unprecedented to provide
financial relief this will be targeted
for workers who are ill quarantined or
caring for others due to corona virus I
will be asking Congress to take
legislative action to extend this relief
well because of the economic policies
that we have put into place over the
last three years
we have the greatest economy anywhere in
the world by far our banks and financial
institutions are capitalized and
incredibly strong
our unemployment is at a historic low
this vast economic prosperity gives us
flexibility reserves and resources to
handle any threat that comes our way
this is not a financial crisis
this is job
a temporary moment of time that we will
overcome together as a nation and as a
world however to provide extra support
for American workers families and
businesses tonight I am announcing the
following additional actions oh I am
instructing the Small Business
Administration to exercise available
authority to provide capital and
liquidity to firms affected by the
corona virus effective immediately the
SBA will begin providing economic loans
in affected states and territories these
low-interest loans will help some
interests overcome temporary economic
disruptions caused by the virus to this
end I am asking Congress to increase
funding for this program by an
additional 50 billion dollars using
emergency Authority I will be
instructing the Treasury Department to
defer tax payments without interest or
penalties for certain individuals and
businesses negatively impacted this
action will provide more than 200
billion dollars of additional liquidity
to the economy finally I am calling on
Congress to provide Americans with
immediate payroll tax relief hopefully
they will consider this very strongly we
are I don't think it's gonna happen at
one time in the fight against the virus
we made a life-saving move with early
action on China or brag now we must take
the shine action with Europe we will not
delay I will never hesitate to take any
necessary steps to protect the lives
health and safety of the American people
I will always put the well-being of
America first if we are vigilant and we
can reduce the chance of infection which
we will we will significantly impede the
transmission of the virus the virus
cannot have a chance
the virus nation is more
prepared or more resilient than the
United States
those are carry had the best economy the
most advanced healthcare and the most
talented doctors scientists and
researchers anywhere in the world we are
all in this together we must put
politics aside stop the partisanship and
unified together as one nation and one
family as history has proven time and
time again Americans always rise to the
challenge and overcome adversity god
bless our future remains brighter than
anyone can imagine
acting with compassion and love we will
heal the sick care for those in need
help our fellow citizens and emerge from
this challenge stronger and more unified
than ever before god bless you and God
bless america
thank you Wow Wow
okay I took notes on basically
everything so we're going to review it
wow wow wow wow wow I mean I don't even
know my real therapy I don't even know
what to make of all of this but it is it
is incredible as you see there Donald
Trump's right eye swollen almost
completely shut during this entire thing
speculation from the audience that he
has the virus literally right now as we
crest 9500 viewers over on YouTube a
thousand on Twitch as well a lot of
interest and I understand why this is
this is really really important stuff I
mean on in a serious sense holy [ __ ]
you thought I froze there for a second
but I didn't know so we're gonna go
through everything Donald Trump says it
was mostly bragging and I think that
that's an important thing to keep in
mind but wow I mean listen if you ask me
what's gonna happen in the stock market
tomorrow I assume it's gonna be very
very very very very very very bad before
before we review everything that
happened let me make sure I'm thanking
everybody if you were just by the way if
you were just looking for the speech and
somehow on YouTube you've ended up on
this completely whacked-out YouTube chat
that I run welcome I'll of that you're
here please make sure to LIKE the stream
and hit the subscribe button it's a
small ask it's really it's just a little
tiny favor that I asked come on by hit
that like button and also hit subscribe
because it's just it's really important
for us that that people help us out with
that stuff so I would appreciate that
okay
a lot of questions from people coming in
let's see here
clever to swear says we must stop the
coronavirus by building a wall giant
squids says these emergency funds are
just going to be another rich guy
developer scam guaranteed grifters gonna
grift yes a lot of grifting there's
certainly a lot of grifting pair tearin'
says i think you can make a bingo chart
every time he talks in crisis I call
sniffing Casper from Denmark says
Denmark for the next two weeks all
schools closed all day care institution
closed excludes all non vital public
employees will stay home all assemblies
with more than 100 people are prohibited
I think I might have missed a few others
name withheld says David I think he has
some kind of implant to keep him from
sniffing Kay Wallace says he's just
learning everything he's reading yeah
Pere says good thing he's reading from a
prompter Joe Rader says the Trump
address is a train wreck
Cameron Titus's Trump sounds ill and
less orange what are your thoughts he
does look less orange with this white
balance yeah Sankyo ship says thoughts
on homeless and inmates through the
crisis about aye that's a it's a whole
problem in and of itself clever to swear
says David you're my favorite gay
teenager and ex white nationalist love
your work and by the way does the Trump
seem out of breath he always sort of
sounds like that a lot of people Erik
Lamont says Trump sounds sick Matt knew
him says Trump dot exe experiencing
technical difficulties
click impeach to continue yeah a lot a
lot going on and some of the super shots
are coming in very very quickly I will
continue to address those if you've just
joined us Donald Trump just finishing
his address let me summarize what was
said and then I'm gonna do new member
thank-yous and and take more questions
from you I see twitch people sending me
messages as well Donald Trump opened
speech with a lot of bragging using the
term that we are using our power to
fight the pandemic bragging about his
insights into early travel closures
which is a lie even after he said China
was shut down flights from China kept
coming in bragging about spending eight
point three billion fighting this
bragging about having the best team
Donald Trump also attacked people he
attacked the European Union for not
acting quickly enough the way he did he
attacked I guess that was the biggest
attack he distorted the number of cases
in the United States again remember he's
talking about the official case number
we're not doing any testing
realistically there are thousands more
cases than Trump is admitting he's also
saying some of our cases are the fault
of China and some of our cases are the
are the fault of Europe and also he
bragged about the greatest economy that
was all the lead up
okay now the policies these are strict
policies but they're not all bad and for
me folks this is not political I want
this dealt with okay I have people in my
family that are immunocompromised there
are older people many you know that I
know in that I don't know doesn't matter
if I know them I just want this dealt
with I don't care who deals with it we
just want it dealt with soon here's what
Donald Trump is doing all travel coming
from Europe is suspended for 30 days you
can't come to the United States from
Europe for 30 days any country this
includes Italy which is ravaged Germany
France Sweden you know all these
different places the UK is exempted from
that the UK is not on the list now at
last check let's just see how UK is
doing in terms of total cases UK 456
they are exempted from from this
proposal Donald Trump did refer to the
South Korea which was weird but not
legislatively consequential Donald Trump
said that he is going to be putting
together some kind of financial relief
for people who are sick quarantined or
taking care of those who are sick or
quarantined I agree with that
it sounds like socialism how will we
ever afford it right but I actually I do
agree with it that's a joke by the way
he is directing the small business
Association to give business loans at
interest to businesses that need it okay
I mean business loans at interest I
don't know is what we need businesses
going into debt at interest at this
point but the idea is to get some cash
there he is also going to propose a
payroll tax cut I read it will be zero
most of if you earn wages up to your
first hundred and thirty seven thousand
a year if you work for an employer you
pay 6.2 percent for the payroll tax
that's a Social Security FICA Medicare
your employer pays the other 6.2 percent
if you're self-employed you pay both
sides of that 6.2 I believe in total
it's like thirteen point one or maybe
it's been dropped a little Trump is
suggesting dropping that to zero through
the end of the year the employee side
he's gonna have to meet with Nancy
Pelosi to make that a reality you do
need the support of the house to do that
and Donald Trump reportedly is refusing
to even meet with Nancy Pelosi that's
what Donald Trump proposed today over on
Twitch let me see what's on people's
minds as people are signing up
cybernetic pean has subscribed crane
says hi David plague of the earth gifted
some subs Jimmy tenpin says David are
you secretly hoping Trump develops an
infection as much as me keep up the
great job I'm not I don't want anybody
to develop the infection red wolf says
hey David so glad you're out here when
Bernie or Buster's like Kyle are ruining
YouTube news oh my god that is
aggressive let me say thanks to some
people who signed up at join pakman.com
guys i so appreciate the people that are
supporting these streams and that
appreciate that that we're doing this
stuff debbie douglas is new member
number three tonight at join pakman.com
Liz Nightingale is new member number
four tonight at join pakman.com Zachary
Stedman you are new member number five
thanks Zack Arthur should see is new
member number six I hope I'm pronouncing
the last name correctly Derrick Shamblin
is new member number seven at join
pakman.com mark Crowell is new member
number eight at join pakman.com Justin
Shepherd
you are new member number nine tonight
Dan blonde oh you are new member number
ten Grayson Fontaine you are new member
number eleven Vikas Mahadeo oh boy I
hope I didn't butcher that you were new
remember number twelve hold on these are
scrolling pretty quickly jason Hankins
you were new member number thirteen and
I think I missed one other one no I did
not okay
uh I really appreciate that guys thank
you and you you can join these fine
folks at join pakman.com it takes it
takes just a moment okay let me see what
other super chats are coming in here I'm
gonna do my best to to get to all of
these and these will show up in the
bottom left of the screen
Allen Bayers says but mr. president
giving government aid to people is
socialism yeah I actually already posted
that if you find folks wanna would
consider giving me a retweet
I actually just posted while we were
listening guys Trump's entire
coronavirus plan sounds like socialism
how can we afford this oh it has 110
retweets already that's not bad
but give him send it over send send a
retweet over on that one at D Pakman
I'll keep it on the screen to see if
anybody actually does it Jeff the god of
biscuits says Trump's plan to fight the
public health threat of kovat 19 is to
focus on the economy sounds about right
he just could he cares about optics and
getting himself reelected mister Pengo
says would you debate Kyle or another
lefty like Michael Brooks on Bernie or
bust versus blue no matter who I don't
see I'm not blue no matter who I'm blue
because it's Biden and Biden's better
than Trump it's not blue no matter who
you could conceivably find someone who's
nominally a Democrat and and I wouldn't
support them no one has signed up at the
soy boy level John Lumley says you
weren't kidding he must barely be able
to see out of his right eye was what is
going on with that yeah it was very
weird
Trump's Trump's right eyes seemingly
swollen almost completely shut and
drooping during most of the speech I
don't really really know what to make of
that James Dean says you're not
gay I'm unsubscribing just kidding keep
it up okay
Gregory shaver says so UK travel is
allowed to the US but continental Europe
is banned for the next 30 days what
about people who go from continental
Europe to the UK they can come here
Actos quid says bah boom in SMB
subsidiaries get low-interest loans
prof danger will the stock market even
open tomorrow at all that's a good
question
Dave Wampler says they've Wampler says
free health care and loans what no Obama
phones Stephen close has grabbed a
YouTube membership clear to swear says
might be a dumb question but why is the
UK exempt I don't know I don't know I
don't know why Nanette burrows has
signed up on YouTube Daniel Krieger says
Kyle kolinsky is great and I'll pay to
say it Jen Cerny says keep up the good
work awesome gaming says Dow Jones
futures are crashing right now let's
take a look at that ok where oh I'm not
seeing futures this is today's numbers
from earlier where do in post trading
hours I'm not sure where to find futures
quite frankly if somebody tells me I
will definitely find that Joseph van
Scoy hey David just watch this is he on
sudafed again no it was not upper Trump
today this was downer Trump sort of a
slower Trump with the sniffing mostly
reading the prompter out of just one eye
it was it was a very very different
different Donald Trump today than the
upper Trump Mike salt says why do you
think Wall Street investors won't like
Trump's address tonight it involved tax
cuts they love tax cuts maybe you're
right I mean listen I can't tolerate too
much more of what's going on when I look
at my I've stopped looking at my mutual
fund account cuz it's brutal
Keaton clapper says will you chest bump
Joe Rogan next time you see him you know
depending on what's going on with Co vid
I may be seeing him sooner then you
might think Kevin Shane says 0% payroll
through the end of the year we'll put
thousands I don't need in my pocket I
would save it not spend it regressive
policy and I hate it you're not wrong
but something that will only affect
people
making under 137,000 is not really
regressive I understand it's regressive
in the sense that somebody earning 135
will save more than someone and earning
35 but everybody earning over 137 has
capped out and so in that sense it's
actually not a bad way to put some more
money in people's pockets let me say
thank you to a few other new members
Jason Soriano is new member number 14
tonight thank you Jason
Sara vessels is new member number 19
Venus Patil is new member number I'm
sorry 15 not 19 V net is new member
number 16 tonight very much appreciate
that and oh one more Jace Edison is new
member number 17 tonight thanks guys I
really appreciate it and if you're if
you're we're just here for the speech
and you're heading out on YouTube please
do hit that like button and subscribe on
your way out just as a favor to me it
really does help our channel and I very
much appreciate that okay let's see here
all Sid Rea says my dad was supposed to
come to DC he was in Germany I'm so
pissed yeah I mean listen there are
going to be exemptions and from said
people can get tested potentially a
sheev Palpatine says call the virus
boomer Doomer is that too much that's a
little much yeah Russell M says Wall
Street Journal for futures let's look
that up WS j futures commodities and
futures Nikkei crude oil yen Dow yeah
I'm just not really seeing it
commodities and futures maybe I'm on the
wrong page as that is that possible let
me see Dow Jones contract futures and
prices okay are these is this a
continuous future that now is down an
additional 2% is that I so that that
maybe what's going on futures maybe down
an additional 2% which would be not not
not good at all it would be a very very
bad thing
to be the case amethyst eyes says Bernie
or bust people not have that much to
lose
interesting pudding pop says doodle
Moodle doodle day Pakman will say
anything as long as you pay nice little
rhyme there Leanne
Amanda Anderson says Trump blaming
Europe is a joke Europe has more cases
because they're testing more it's been
circulating in the States for weeks
absolutely
clever to swear says what was that fall
out of your Biden over Trump tweet
yesterday I'm guessing people hated it
no so that's it that's it look at that
yesterday man we've got to scroll really
far back yesterday I tweeted which one
was it oh here is I said so listen
there's no doubt Biden's not a
progressive I want him not Trump
choosing RBG's replacement his climate
plan is better than Trump's his health
care plan is milquetoast but it's better
than what Trump wants to do little us to
say it was my most liked tweet of the
day
3,600 likes and a whole bunch of
important blue check people followed me
and said that they appreciated my calm
and rational perspective on the issue so
it so it actually was good it was a very
solid tweet for me let's see here size
says I'm with David I'll vote for Biden
because I will not hand Trump another
justice pic without a fight thanks to a
user whose username is punctuation and
another one whose name is Shirley
Cochran four new memberships name
withheld says Tom Hanks has coronavirus
it's trending is that true
let me look that up Tom Hanks
coronavirus Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson
have tested positive that is indeed true
Dillinger C addict cNN has futures
should be on page one of Google search
Dow futures okay page one of Google
search futures business CNN very good uh
stock futures down down down ok yeah so
everything is down about one one
percentage point right now is roughly
roughly where we are over on twitch I
really want to say thanks to some people
who just signed up let's see here
boom ffice has grabbed the switch Prime
subscription Quantum Palash has
subscribed with Prime and debate me TV
has subscribed with prime I do want to
say thanks to some other new members
that join pakman.com very very excited
to see that
Petrina Petrina Biondo Petrina Biondo is
new member number 18 tonight
Thalia Colt Rona is new member number 19
tonight and Richard Fairburn is new
member number 20 tonight we are very
very close to the very modest goal of
just 25 new members tonight I'll do yep
I see people asking about free stuff
what's better than free stuff right
member number 25 tonight if we get one
gets a free item from the David Pakman
show store we've got t-shirts coffee
mugs all sorts of stuff
number 25 will get a free item of your
choice from the online store let's see
here
ac says thanks for bringing me back to
reality I was falling hard to the Bernie
election was stolen conspiracy Kevin de
Lu says look into the mess at the
Houston Stock Show I'll check that out
for tomorrow
Russell M says Tom Hanks and wife have
the corona virus yep we just found that
amethyst eyes do Bernie or bust people
not have as much to lose
I love Bernie but I cannot put up with
Trump and cannot understand how they can
be short-sighted
I mean listen I'm not a bernie or buster
you'd have to talk to them about why it
is that that that's how they feel
because it's certainly not not how I
feel let me say thank you to Ross W
Lewis let's look again at some of the
latest numbers as I pointed out earlier
if there is any good news in what is
going on one bit of good news is that
China is shedding about a thousand
active cases a day because through
authoritarian police state measures they
have reduced the new cases to about
twenty a day while they are clearing
about a thousand recovered people a day
so China's rapidly improving the
situation Italy is a disaster but if you
say can I find anything
less than terrible in the Italy numbers
it is essentially this right here and it
is that the curve of new cases has
flattened and if you look at the new
cases by day yesterday there was a
significant reduction in new cases in
Italy the hope is and we will hopefully
have the March 11th information soon in
the next few hours certainly the hope is
that this number of new cases in Italy
goes down again for March 11 the idea
being over time you get fewer and fewer
new cases per day
the other bit of good news is that
places that are doing widespread testing
which really means South Korea South
Korea's death rate is 0.7 and that's
much better than the 3.4 death rate that
that has been floating around which is
uh you know it would be an even more
tragically high death rate okay let's
see Brody Andrew Mulligan says your work
keeps me going when days are tough
wanted to thank you patent acts well
let's not forget about Noah we're
working hard here in Texas keep it up
also play rudiments sometimes Steve pip
says the Bernie or bust crew are sick of
the treatment we've received since 2016
the Supreme Court is the only reason I'm
voting for Biden and a good reason I
would say oh go back to your chart it
shows the new number hold on a second
the new number of Italy cases is that
what we're talking about
I just unsure what people are saying I
don't see what when people say it shows
the new number I don't see it I'm sorry
guys am I missing which chart did you
guys want me to go back to that has the
new number
let me look very closely at the chat
because I don't want to miss it if
indeed there is something there at the
bottom at the bottom of what
this the bottom this is the chart right
977 I'm sorry what are people talking
about March 10 March 10
hover over the bar yes I'm hovering over
the bar under new cases the chart over
there guys I don't know what you guys
are talking about I'm just not seeing
the March 11th numbers yeah I just don't
know what people are talking about or do
you mean oh oh [ __ ] do you mean this is
the new number for today 2 3 1 3 or
we're [ __ ] if that's the case oh my
goodness that is absolutely insane if 2
3 1 3 is the number of new cases today
then were Italy is what this is
absolutely a frickin disaster ok sorry
guys now I under I'm sorry that that was
so difficult but that's really that's
like that's weaponized bad it's uh ok
yeah that's that's not good that's not
good I'm actually stunned by that number
2 3 1 3 oh my goodness that is just a
stunning number that is a stunning
number that's depressing ok so anyway
that was one bit of possible good news
that I that I was not planning on the
NBA season has been canceled is that
true NBA season canceled could that
really be true
ok I'm not seeing that that is but that
has been cancelled now I'm not seeing
that they'll probably play in front of
empty stadiums okay let's see here James
Dean's or no I'm sorry um Apocrypha
Jones says thanks for keeping us
actually informed keep up the good work
James Dean says I wasn't sure if I was
going to vote until I seen your video
and I agree Biden is better than Trump
not much but better nor Ibaka hospitals
are checking for coronavirus at the door
in Cleveland closing colleges but not
stopping visits from visitors that has
to be addressed Caleb I hae a-- says do
you disagree with all the
implementations of public option or just
Biden's per
particular implementation I don't
disagree with it if you tell me we do
nothing or at a public option I want the
public option but the public option is a
milquetoast place to start
I want much more than the public option
to begin with oh and you said that the
name is pronounced a hiya
Caleb a hiya thank you cinema pidgin
says do you think Biden's mental decline
is overrated exaggerated or fake I think
it is exaggerated this next coming
debate between him and Bernie could give
us answers yeah listen watch Biden's
speech last night extemporaneous calm
reasoned Biden has a stutter I'm not
saying every time he glitches it's a
stutter he is 78 almost everybody who is
at 78 who is 78 is less sharp than they
were at 62 that's a reality and all of
the city you know there's a lot of
cynical bad actors who have never said a
word about Trump's cognitive issues and
are all over Biden at this point I mean
listen do it it's just gonna get Trump
reelected if you don't care then go
ahead and do it Walter says an NBA
player has tested positive for
coronavirus don't know if that's true
Jacob Ratner says my school moved online
today due to the virus clever to swear
rest in peace Italy thanks for the pasta
and pizza dough that though that's
horrible
phony K the second David if Biden
doesn't offer anything to Bernie
supporters why should we enable the
apathy towards us I believe he will be
extending an olive branch
Jesus was a communist sends a message
not a message of super chat name
withheld David will you stop streaming
if you get it Torre will you stick with
us until the end I would try to stream
from home if I got it and it wasn't
serious Daniel Neil studying in Germany
chances I'll be recalled don't know
gotta talk to the embassy Dion Key says
NBA player Rudy Gobert test positive for
virus if that's the case it may spread
within the NBA and that will become very
quickly problematic you're not going to
be able to have crowds when the players
have it let me say thank you and welcome
to Luis Cardinal who is new member
number 21 on my website at join
pakman.com and Zach Williams who is new
member number 22 the
four is still open new member number 25
tonight you get a free item from my
website grab a coffee mug t-shirt
anything you want
over on Twitch let me say thank you to
Miz juxta for the twitch Prime
subscription Blue Bunny for the tier one
subscription geek chic who has
subscribed with prime did I say that
correctly geek oh no it's geek I think
that's the username and Ross W Lewis who
has also subscribed with prime if you're
watching on YouTube make sure to both
like the stream and hit the subscribe
button
I very much appreciate that
Tom Hanks tested positive we know that
Italy numbers are terrifying but I
laughed out loud from David dropping the
f-bomb if somebody can clip that that
would be good Zachary Monroe do you
think there should be an age cap for
political office I think it's very
people have asked me about that I think
it's very very problematic to do
Alejandro Sanchez says Tom Hanks tested
positive we know that heard about it
says the NBA has it suspended its season
/ Br I don't know what that is I don't
know what B R is Gabe McCoy says we're
just running the the repeat here Gabe
McCoy says are you hardline in favor of
Medicare for all do you have any
reservations well I think it'll just
cost way more than anybody who has a
plan for it is telling us ESPN says that
the NBA season has been suspended let's
look at that ESPN the jazz and thunder
players are quarantined in Oklahoma City
Wow oh my goodness
let's look again at ESPN the NBA has
suspended the season Wow
Wow let's see what this report is here
the Dumbledore and no player has left
the arena yet and and we've been in this
spot basically since the moment that
they officially postponed the game so
from what we
right now the players are being I don't
know if I want to call it held behind
those double doors but they are not
leaving a lot of them are confused as to
why they are not leaving the arena as of
yet there was somebody that a thunder
staffer that just came walking by and he
was going to hand off a backpack and
they opened the doors very very lightly
and he just passed it through and they
wouldn't even let him go back there so
there's a lot of confusion as to what
what is going on back in that area right
now but they did when they did call the
game Scott one of the things that the
public address announcer did say is he
made an announcement that the game has
been postponed due to unforeseen
circumstances but he assured fans twice
that they are safe and he made sure to
say rather and fatica Lee and asked
everybody to leave the arena quite
slowly so we're sitting here wondering
if we're gonna see a player walk down
this hallway or even a thunderstorm
Wow so point because it's it's quite
unknown as to what's going on back
behind those double doors right now
Royce appreciate you boots on the ground
we'll update that as we can how
depressing guys how depressing this this
is just absolutely terrible let's see
what else is on people's minds si
Pfeiffer sends a some kind of thumbs up
graphic Lee an Amanda Anderson says
people need to understand exponential
growth it's Italy now but all those
countries in the hundreds will follow if
they don't get on top of it yes they do
mubashir says i am mainly concerned
about Congress at this straight Congress
will be overwhelmed with conservatives
there won't be any dem to counterbalance
that machine XP Westfield Massachusetts
shut down college campus yep I have
friends who teach there GQ wincy says
there won't be fans in the stands during
the March Madness tournament everyone
stays safe
MMC will one has grabbed a soy boy
subscription tasty McKee McLain has
grabbed a soy boy subscription clever to
swear says no I wanted lot LeBron to win
that championship ring and dr. Terry
White has grabbed a soy boy level
subscription as well not a great day
guys not not a great day at all in terms
of news I would expect at the rate
things are going in a lot of countries
I'm not really optimistic that the next
few days are going to be good
but we will see if anybody can get it
turned around the way China has of
course China doing it with authoritarian
police state measures that I have a very
hard time imagining would ever fly ever
ever ever in the United States so I
genuinely don't know what is going to
happen
Joseph Dizzy's says chances Trump has
kovat not good if that's true I don't
know he's been in touch with people who
have been exposed I don't know
Dustin DPS says all of Florida campuses
shut down for two weeks shut down for
two weeks
oh and our southern nest adventure also
said this man needs to go he is a liar
don't know if you're talking about me or
Trump is let me say thank you to poon
harpoon for subscribing with twitch
Prime and run Baron has also subscribed
with twitch prime appreciate that as
well if people are wondering what
website has all of these statistics I
find this to be the best website it's
world emitters dot info like world
ohmmeter with an S plural world o meters
dot info slash coronavirus and I find
that that this is probably the best the
best website for this I know that the
NBA is canceled yes we just looked at a
video we just saw that news reported by
the by the by ESPN ESPN has report
reported that and it is it is not good
people asking what I'm doing I mean
listen maybe I'm basically am i altering
my behavior I'm probably going out less
I'm not seeking out large crowds I'm not
going to food truck festivals I'm not
going to stuff like that I'm opting you
know when I go to a coffee shop I'm
opting for a less crowded coffee shop
generally although today I didn't do
that I went to like a college coffee
shop filled with college students who
have probably been all over the world I
am I am eating out I'm not really
avoiding restaurants I'm washing my
hands more I do have a trip coming up in
12 days and you know I have to think
about whether I'm gonna do that again I
still think mathematically the odds of
me just I don't know the odds if I'm in
Boston and
restaurants and cafes and at my gym and
they're doing what they can at my gym
but I don't know that I'm really more
likely to catch it if I go to Florida
which is where I'm scheduled to go to
but I don't know I'm gonna do the trips
not for a couple of weeks I'm gonna
decide maybe in ten days or something
like that clever to swear says Weinstein
also got 23 years he's Coronis safe not
so much it seems Rikers might be having
a problem Peter Hogan de Paul says NYC
Metro is starting to get it bad stay
safe stay home if you can thanks for the
great news keep being awesome the
Buckman ater Beckham inator says hey
David what's the best advice to avoid
depression while paying attention to
news in politics take breaks from it and
read you know good fiction books listen
to music exercise team sports although
you know team sports right now with
coronavirus who knows that's at your own
at your own discretion but it does feel
like things have gotten very very real
all of a sudden let me say thank you to
Michael Turpin Michael topic is new
member number 23 tonight we are two
members at join pakman.com from hitting
our goal of 25 I've already put on
record new member number 25 you get a
free item from my online store my online
store has all sorts of t-shirts you know
what let's actually see what I have on
my online store I don't even remember
always what it is that I have see if we
can find some of these items oh no don't
tell me my webs ok so let's see so we've
got all the basic t-shirts and all of
that type of stuff we've got coffee mugs
to color coffee mugs white and black
those are cool we have the oh this is a
great t-shirt right here this is the if
Ivanka weren't my daughter t-shirt in
unisex and let's see man the website is
just so I think there's a bunch of
people trying to sign up I apologize for
that our hosting is supposed to
dynamically adjust to the amount of
demand but it doesn't really seem to be
happening that much anyway that's the if
Ivanka weren't my daughter shirt there's
all sorts of stuff but in any case new
member number 25 I will get you get you
a free item and we're very close
clever
sware says who's the greatest of all
time magnus carlsen or garry kasparov
you know gary is not rated at his peak
right now and i don't know if there if
there's been raiding inflation but I
believe Magnus is rated higher or was
rated higher than Gary ever was but
again if there's been raiding inflation
that may not be relevant a Guillermo
Gomez jr. says NBA jazz player Rudy
Gobert tested positive yes we have
reported that and we we are very very
much aware of it let me say thank you to
Eric red for the twitch subscription
moon Raven for the twitch subscription
and Junior dubs with a Z for the twitch
subscription Troy broken Shire is new
member
that was weird if you were waiting for
member number 24 to grab a membership
yourself and to hoard the free item from
member number 25 this is the time to get
the membership because we are one away
from 25 also thanks to Fras de for
subscribing with prime would I be open
let's see Karen Brannon young would I be
open to debating Kyle kolinsky on
whether or not the left should vote
Biden you know I do i we were we were
were we going back and forth on Twitter
about that today maybe we were I don't
want to do anything that's gonna make it
more likely for Trump to win and I don't
know if debating this having it out with
someone on my side is going to help get
Trump out so I'd have to think about the
impact of it awesome gaming says OKC
Thunder and jazz are in quarantine yes
indeed I smile serrano the Clippers
can't dominate like they were supposed
to
Heather bender has grabbed a youtube
subscription jock Buster has grabbed the
YouTube subscription remember that the
25 thing is subscriptions on my website
at join pakman.com Santa Clause says hey
David you should sell bumper sticker so
we can spam your logo everywhere look we
do sell bumper stickers they're on david
pakman.com slash gear logo recognition
is way important to combat mainstream
media bumper stickers widely widely
available shannon dennis has great how
trump sincerely asked for non partisan
right because he's been so non partisan
all this entire time
oh somebody somebody clipped me finding
the bat finding out the bad news let's
just let's just see this i think this
will be oh here's the if Ivanka weren't
my daughter shirt very very popular item
okay let's see here oh wait no clips
twitch clips this should be kind of
funny this is when I found out Italy did
not have a good day at all in terms of
new cases I'm just not seeing the March
11th numbers yeah I just don't know what
people are talking about or do you mean
oh oh [ __ ] do you mean this is the new
number for today 2 3 1 3 well we're
[ __ ] if that's the case oh my goodness
that is absolutely insane if 2 3 1 3 is
the number of new cases today
then were with Italy is what this is
absolutely a freaking disaster I was not
seeing them are there it is
so now someone clip me watching my own
clip and then we could actually go three
level levels deep that would be that
would be interesting as well okay let's
see what else did I want to address here
I already thanked Fras de we did shan't
the Shannon Bennis super chat already
and I think I'm basically caught up at
this point in time we do know that the
NBA has this quarantine situation going
we know that Tom Hanks Rita Wilson not
Tom Hanks thanks hmm well this is going
to get more people paying attention
right that's for sure okay folks Rita
and I are down here in Australia we felt
a bit tired like we had colds and some
body aches Rita had chills that came and
went slight fevers to play it right we
were tested for coronavirus and were
found positive the medical officials
have protocols that must be followed
we Hanks will be tested observed and
isolated for as long as required not
much more to it than a one day at a time
approach will keep the world posted and
updated Wow and also a picture of a sock
so a lot happening that is that is uh
you know it's just one more person it's
two more people but it does make people
think very very much about what's going
on all right real quick we're just gonna
do this one more just because we eat a
little levity here is me watching myself
on Twitch I just don't know what people
are talking about or do you mean Oh oh
[ __ ] do you mean this is the new number
for today two three one three well we're
[ __ ] if that's the case oh my goodness
that is absolutely insane
Wow if 2 3 1 3 is the number of new
cases today
then we're with Italy is of what this is
absolutely a frickin disaster I'm not
seeing them Arthur alright good so we
did we did the inception thing now we've
watched me watching me react if anybody
okay if people want to go one more level
deep we can do one more level if people
people want to do one more level
Jakub Sabula says does AirTrain
include cargo planes there's a case of
cargo handlers exposed to cv when
touching cargo I don't know the answer
to that this game this is gonna be good
know it investing indices futures chart
Google hit number one will bring you two
falling chart on investing.com
investing indices future chart okay
let's look at that and then we will go
one more level deep on investing.com
live chart okay here it is
oh boy down three and a half percent
again yeah it's gonna be very bad
tomorrow all right here's the last one
guys me watching me watching this is the
new number for today two three one three
well we're [ __ ] if that's the case oh
my goodness that is absolutely insane
Wow if two three one three is the number
of new cases incredibly then were Italy
is what this is absolutely a disaster I
was not seeing them Arthur alright good
so we did did the inception thing now
we've won okay and then now we paused me
pausing me doing the watching of the
inception thing I think this has to be
done guys I think that's it there's no
more that that has to be the end because
otherwise things are gonna get a little
too out of control I don't think we're I
don't think we can go any deeper okay
clever to swear says isn't 2020 the best
year ever so far Lew Minya says love you
David Val says you know I love your show
but why are you giving up on Bernie when
half the country hasn't voted yet
Val I I'm not giving up I am reporting
math and data okay we now have new
member number 25 getting a free item let
me figure out exactly who is new member
number 25 new member number 25 today is
Tristen
Lucero Tristen Lucero you are new member
number 25 you get a free item from my
website use the contact form and let me
know what you want address all of that
stuff also want to say thanks to Garre
on elvers Garre on elvers is new member
to number 26 tonight and lastly I also
want to say thanks to Mary Kate's
Olsen no I'm kidding mary-kate carlson
mary-kate carlson is new member number
27 tonight at join pakman.com I much
appreciate that very very exciting ok
this is absolutely the last inception
clip okay this is it and then we're
gonna be done for the night
me watching this is the new number for
today two three one three well we're
[ __ ] if that's the case oh my goodness
that is absolutely insane Wow
if 2 3 1 3 is the number of new cases
incredible geez then were absolutely not
seeing all right good so we did did the
inception thing now we've won okay and
then now we paused me pausing me doing
the watching of the inception thing and
then now we're pausing that pause and
then deleting all evidence of this from
anything that has ever ever ever
happened before okay let's see Peter
Hogan DePaul says getting HTTP errors on
your website everybody is trying to sign
up at once it does appear that way there
is a crazy amount of activity on the
website its wild what is going on I
think the website may have crashed
because so many people were trying to
get memberships isn't that bonkers okay
in any case that is going to do it for
today I was not even planning on
streaming today and I appreciate
everybody who joined me very important
message from Donald Trump we're going to
have coverage of this and somebody
please email me the final inception clip
because we will be posting it to social
media thank you for joining me